President Biden is
on the defensive again tonight
amid mounting questions
over his handling
of classified documents.
This as a powerful House
Republican begins probing the U.
Justice Department's
response to the matter.
Our chief White House
correspondent Phil
Mattingly has the latest
on the first full day of a presi
under investigation, an attempt
to focus on business as usual.
You know,
we meet a remarkable moment, our
President Biden
welcoming Japanese Prime Ministe
Kishida to the White House.
To highlight
a transformational shift
in the Pacific
nation's security posture is the
as he ignored questions
about the special counsel
now investigating his handling
of classified documents
after his time as vice president
and his press
secretary continue to deflect
or declined to answer.
Critical, outstanding questions.
I'm not going to go
into any specifics from here.
If you have any questions,
anything further
that's related to the review, or
I will refer you to the Departme
of Justice
or my colleagues
over at the White House Counsel'
for Biden, who has maintained th
People know
I take classified documents
of classified material seriously
even as the scale of the problem
has mushroomed into a crisis ove
just five days.
We're cooperating fully,
complete with the
Justice Department's review.
The outward appearance of normal
serving to cover
what has been described
by officials
behind the scenes as a scramble
to adjust to a new normal,
all as new details
emerge from the initial batch
of ten classified documents
discovered at a Biden affiliated
think tank stored in Biden's off
Their floor
plans show a small closet
to the left of Biden's
desk and storage spaces
in the adjoining conference room
The documents
include a memo from Biden to the
President Obama,
as well as two briefing memos
prepared for Biden, phone calls
with the British prime minister
and the president
of the European Council.
We have been transparent
in the last couple of days in me
There's an ongoing process
and we have spoken
when it is appropriate,
even as details
of another set of classified
documents found at Biden's
Wilmington home in his garage
in an adjacent room
remain under wraps
after their existence
was publicly revealed
nearly a month after their disco
my conventional locked garage.
Okay,
so it's not like you're sitting
the street,
just one of the many questions
that remain unanswered.
For a White House
facing a most perilous moment,
we have said that
we are going to continue to cont
fully cooperate. We have been
the president's
lawyers and team
has been fully cooperating
with the Department of Justice.
And we're certainly
they're certainly going to do th
with the special counsel.
And, Wolf,
one of the biggest outstanding
questions is the origin
of those documents,
how they got to the two location
where they were found.
And in reporting
on those final weeks for Joe
Biden as vice president,
what was made clear
by officials
that were familiar
with that moment in time
was just how disjointed that pro
Biden was on the road
visiting Ukraine, visiting
Davos, meeting with foreign lead
It was very much almost
an acceleration of his work,
something that made it
extremely difficult for staff
trying to pack up and close
out that office.
However, however,
the documents ended up in the
two locations
now currently under investigatio
You can add the House Judiciary
to those looking into this proce
The new chairman of that committ
Jim Jordan,
sending a letter to the Justice
Department, making clear
his committee had opened an inve
and asking for a wide range of d
and what is expected
to be one of several probes
from Capitol Hill.
The administration is facing as
with this new special counsel Wo
Phil Mattingly at the White Hous
thank you very much.
Let's discuss all of this
and more with our senior
legal analyst, Elie Honig.
CNN senior political commentator
David Axelrod
and CNN political analyst
Maggie Haberman.
She's a senior political corresp
at The New York Times.
David, let me start with you.
The Biden White House has so far
been unable
to fully explain its delay in
disclosing the discovery
of these additional classified d
If you were advising President B
right now,
we know you used to advise
President Obama.
What would you tell him to do ri
Well,
look, I
mean, from a political
and communications standpoint,
the essence of crisis
communications is to get everyth
as quickly as possible.
And and go from there.
And that hasn't happened here
for whatever reason.
You know,
the original discovery was made.
It took
several months to learn about th
A second
discovery was made on December 2
And so and I think this has crea
problems, perhaps more problems
than they would have had
if they had been more
forthcoming from the beginning.
But I don't know what advice
they're getting.
Well, from their lawyers,
I don't know what requests
they've gotten from
the Justice Department.
I just would caution this.
You know, we of all everyone on
this panel has lived through
these kinds of stories
over a long period of time,
and they always start as five
alarm fires.
It takes a while to really deter
whether they are,
in fact, five alarm fires
or just bonfires that ultimately
get extinguished.
This one feels to me
like it's going to be that.
But it also depends on
whether there are more revelatio
to come.
Good point.
You know, Maggie,
there are now special counsels,
as you know,
looking into both the current
and former president's
handling of highly classified ma
Does this lower the temperature
right now?
I think
politically is
different than legally, Wolf.
I think David is exactly right
in terms of the politics of this
And the crisis calms aspects of
in terms of being a problem
for the current White House.
And I think that,
you know,
at least from the position
short term position of Republica
and Trump supporters,
you know, more advantageous for
just in terms of muddying the wa
But these are two
separate investigations.
And while,
yes, there are aspects of
these two instances in cases and
that look similar
from what we know
and again, to David's point,
there's still a lot to learn.
But from what we know,
these are not identical situatio
The main difference is just
the alleged obstruction
by Donald Trump
over and over and over
for a very long period of time
when when the archives were tryi
to get these records back
and then when the Justice Depart
got involved,
that I do think that the Trump
people feel like this
makes it easier for them.
Again,
I think that is purely
from the standpoint of, you know
the public is probably not
paying attention to the fine poi
the fine points of this
That's part of, I
think, why
some Democrats are frustrated
that there hasn't
been more coming
from the current White House.
That's a good point.
How much pressure
is the US Department of Justice
right now
as it tries to navigate these du
into both Biden and Trump?
Well,
I think this is
an unprecedented situation
for the Justice Department.
Never before
have we had a special counsel
investigating a sitting presiden
At the same time,
a separate
special counsel is investigating
not just the prior president
but these two people are likely
to be running against each other
in the next election.
Now, by the book here, just lega
speaking, these are, as Maggie s
separate investigations,
separate special prosecutors,
special separate fact.
And Merrick Garland,
what he ought to do
is let both of those investigati
play out.
And when the special counsel
come back to him,
then he will make his decision
but I think Garland
also has to be aware
of the political reality here,
that if he is to decide one way
that will change the temperature
and the pressure on the other.
So, America,
that's got to do a balancing act
He's a very by the book attorney
But he also is aware,
I believe, of the real world and
the political reality.
We're learning.
Then Vice
President Biden's aides scramble
David, to close his office
during what's
being described
as an unusually busy final few d
Can you give us a sense
of what goes into wrapping up
and packing up
a presidential administrations
work at the end of the term?
Well, at the end of two terms, W
is what we're talking about here
eight years of history.
And, you know,
the vice president
probably saw thousands of docume
and briefing materials
over the course of those years.
So it's not it's not at all
surprising to me
that there could be mistakes
like this made.
One of the things that really do
differ between these two cases
beyond what was already mentione
is that Donald Trump doesn't eve
that he took the documents.
He acknowledges
that he took these documents.
He maintains that through some m
incantation, he made them
he took Top-Secret documents
and declassified them.
But but he he acknowledges
he took the documents.
What the Biden folks are saying
this was an inadvertent mistake
and that they
as soon as they found out about
they returned the documents.
And, of course,
that's what
these special counsels will be e
And this exploration
is only just beginning right now
Guys, thank you very, very much.